eh take one mark Neil Patrick Harris is  latest endeavor best time ever  premieres Tuesday it's essentially seven  new shows happening simultaneously it's  a party and as part of it he pranks  unsuspecting celebrities Gwen Stefani  from no doubts she's beautiful like dog  no that was not good enough oh yes NPH  pulled the ultimate prank on The Voice  coaches and he dished to et all about it  I hadn't almost three hours of  prosthetic makeup on had a different  accent  it was incredibly terrifying they  thought I was insane bleak now that  shows successful coach on the voice what  else do you coach now what else do I  coach Little League I think they thought  something was up because who asks weird  questions like that anymore otherwise  you'd say what the f is this said you  walk away so they were looking at me  like what in the world but they didn't  know it was me and it was fun it was fun  to get to play with them oh it's for  real  you guys ready  you